all right it's all better now
okay cool we said no it's okay okay hey
Nico are you having fun on set yep we
are in the great outdoors in Yosemite
Valley seven hours north of Los Angeles
for all intents and purposes off the
grid we're out here doing a brand deal
with hex shot foam blaster Clinton you
go put together this awesome script
based around fortnight and foam blasters
so we've got the whole crew out here or
most of the crew of the couple extra
friends out here for a few days it's not
an easy feat if you want to make sure if
we make a good impression we get in here
we execute on our game plan and really
make an awesome video once again guys
we're the farmer tan brothers our power
is a dynamic tonality between our elbows
and our shoulders it impresses people it
dazzles people and it started numerous
Wars that we are here to fight that was
far more eloquent than what I was gonna
say I was gonna say just blind people
but today I'm acting it means I stand
around a lot more than these two it
makes me really anxious
every shot Arsenal will have every type
of thing you might need they got many
pistols we got submachine guns assault
rifles and sniper rifles whether it
suits your fancy
we got Clint is directing this piece we
have a great DP our third toe here and a
friend Paul really when it comes down to
his clintus vision he's seeing this
thing he has it and it says it's really
up to good to help communicate to that
through the team and really help us
execute what he sees in his head and
what we can make happen in real life
all right let's watch it it looks pretty
good you get closer okay oh my god
that's hilarious
I have fun guys
man this your first up please are you
doing what I'm doing what do you do my
teammate the rules count one thousand
two one thousand three one thousand four
one thousand
[Music]
well just a little audio problem just to
kind of no not yet but as soon as we
there's one what do we do the take it's
gonna pop let's just roll it why don't
we get the zoom in just save time bring
logic into this we want to make sure
audio is the best because if it isn't
then it's not up to court or digital
standard it's up to Wong foo film
standard all right guys let's go let's
do this right now
three two one action good eye by trade I
earn a DI T what does the F G stand for
there's no image room technician unlike
what most people think I don't handle
media in any way so that means on a
movie I control exposure I have an
awareness handset that's connected to
the iris motor if you walk onto a big
movie set you sometimes might think that
the IITs a focus puller I deal with
color of the movie the nut that we use
to monitor the whole show certain DPS I
work with hop from one camera to another
they have to trust that those two
monitors but that's their correct
lighting ratio what kind of movies have
you worked on worked a bit on the new
Blade Runner I did all of revenant the
nice guys live by night end of watch who
does dump the media then loader to get a
shot right it really takes every staff
person to really have nailed that shot
so on revenant as di T I'll be standing
right next to the cinematographer
because he's pretty picky about exposure
as well so he'll always want to glance
at my false-color monitor and say are
make sure you're not too bright you're
not too hot or stuff down here or he'll
tell me like I'm gonna whip pan from
here to here so you have to be prepared
to stop down from this side to this side
or you know our actors gonna go low into
the ground and the snow and it's gonna
get dark behind this rock and I just
have to know what's going on and watch
the rehearsals he's also right next to
the DP the Keanu monitor and controlling
focus and listening to the DP saying Oh
I'm in a pan left or you know we'll be
on HIV communicators so we can talk
during the shot and just kind of whisper
to each other we'll hear each other it's
a very interesting setup for cameras
super efficient you can talk during the
shot yeah that's kind of the method that
most movies are working now like a lot
of movies now like to do iris pulls in
the lighting of room to match an outside
exposure shot in revenant we will run
through the snow and it goes inside a
cabin and I remember from that shot I
was pulling from a 22 to a 1/3 just
right as they open the door is a big old
racking and several times I I was the
one that botched it up because it was
added too fast or too early or too soon
you could see the change and then if I
got a right maybe the focus puller
missed one so that so to get a shot
right it really takes every staff person
to really have nailed that shot you guys
had all those super long shots and long
takes did you have to rehearse just like
a crap-ton to be able to do like a
rehearsal in a time rehearsed eight to
ten hours and then shot right at Magic
Hour we call it panic hour Wow just
rehearse and rehearse remember to get it
right and get it right that's how much
time it would take to really nail down
the beats you would think that when a
horse runs by and the camera just goes
right that you get what you get but
we'll watch it back and say no this
needs to be a hair lower and touch to
the right it needs to be like dialed in
we can just kind of keep going until the
Sun until the light really doesn't let
us go anymore and a lot of times on them
there are a lot of night torch scenes so
a lot of times when we do get what we
want we bring out the torches and we
start the night work did you sleep in a
horse too I don't think any of us ever
slept in a horse we look at their
matching just look at that game and plan
yeah I mean look okay if you've ever
played make-believe or ever like played
with your toys if you're a girl you
played with your Barbies boy you played
with your Barbies a girl you played with
your construction trucks whatever you
played with whatever your toy was we're
or just were we get paid to play
make-believe like we committed to that
in our childhood and we were like the
is what we're gonna do we're just
playing around and it's our job like how
[ __ ] sick now as a kid I
I have high-functioning autism so I
spent a lot of time reading by myself
few times I got to talk to adults it was
great but most of the time hanging out
with kids my own age wasn't the easiest
thing to do a better I got at telling
stories even my own stories better I got
it making friends something and that's
kinda what happened grow up grow up and
became a couple became a person that
sounds really super cheesy I know you're
like whoa too happy but one's assuming
it and then flash-forward and I applied
to screenwriting school at USC getting
to go to work with my paternal parent
television the you love content that
much as a kid kept like yeah did you
consume it where did you get it when you
were attending I mean if you got to go
rent a movie every weekend you know from
the video store and that was your tree
yeah we go to theaters rent a video game
once in a while couldn't buy them very
often it's only get one for your
birthday want for Christmas and what if
you saved up put a lot of hours in the
pit of dark and gold yeah 61 icicles but
well yeah there's no other one though
it's something about like movies back
then they feel like such a bigger
accomplishment and achievement yeah it's
probably cuz I'm a lot closer to the
industry how it was then it just feels
so much more money driven now one of the
most famous professors at USC his name's
Drew Casper he gets paid by the Alfred
Hitchcock Foundation that's the semester
by saying welcome to the best Film
School in the world
I'm drew Casper you are about to learn
how to make the movies that changed your
life I'm sorry there's not going to be
any more magic you're going to know how
they did it but you can make that
feeling happen for someone else but drew
Casper was right it's only gone so that
we can share with others now we're
custodians of it we're like part of the
Speed Force the Speed Force isn't fast
it's just a speed force maybe a person
got into a speed force they become fast
speed forces just speed force does that
seem a little that was that just a
little dowel all of a sudden actually
I've never I don't know it's peak force
this
oh it's what the flash taps into that
gives him his speed it's like the yeah
you gotta be one with the movies it
makes sense
yeah it doesn't make sense I know what I
like acting it's fun it's also really
hard so here's the thing about being an
actor you get to sit around while
everybody else stresses out about the
shoes you just say why you got preserve
your energy and stay in character yeah I
get to be an [ __ ] because it keeps me
jovial and in character whereas every
else has to be focused and on task
seriously after like directing and
producing and all that kind of stuff
knowing all the work that these guys
have to do just sitting and watching and
just gotta keep my costume together
gotta keep my hair brushed you gotta
work on not intervening mm-hmm yeah it's
been it's been hard but you know good
job not interviewing them you only step
in when it's like you have either a
really really good idea or it's like an
emergency hey Nico can you hold this are
you staying out as pranksters all the
time and the most common you need to do
prank
especially on tour just called the
tickle bug all you need is something
like this you just somebody
[Music]
so yeah Nico you're crying already
it must be above our special rolling
rolling
Oh
so I'm down when you're a movie star
what you do on a set like this is I
actually don't know I'm not movie star
we are literally chasing the Sun
okay new rule oh is it now we could
probably go shots from up there
[Music]
that's what's one action new rules oh
yeah I think used to say back in the 80s
the ex shot in the Hayfield it's hard to
find we need bread straight for some Sun
things change some script revisions had
to happen in order to logistical II
actually complete our shoot but in the
end we're finishing we got it done we're
gonna hang out tonight and head back
home tomorrow do we have everything we
need to tell a good story absolutely do
we have everything we need to make a
good quarter video absolutely do we have
everything we need that the brand wants
I'm pretty sure we're close interesting
story to tell we rode our one wheels
quite a bit when we were riding it
around then our lead actor Leo DiCaprio
who was always watching us and we didn't
know but he was jealous that he couldn't
ride it but we didn't know this
on the last day as soon as they called
that's a picture wrap and he goes right
away he just points and he goes can I
ride it oh yeah you'll see I've always
wanted to ride it what you had 10 months
to ask it's like why didn't you write
ask us earlier as I can't the insurance
company won't let me
you can't while you're gone you're
bonded on a movie you can do it ok so he
hops on hold someone's elbow
while they know is that like literally
this person is his first try and then
you didn't have any wobbles at all he's
good at everything he does do do that
she's ever heard of a hundred mile race
a hundred mile a hundred mile one wheel
race the thing about bears because if
you encounter them in the forest
it's very backwards than what you would
think can't outrun a bear you can't out
climb a bear you can't outswim a bear
and if you lay there and it's coming for
you it's just gonna eat you
so that leaves you one option fight the
bear this is serious
you leave your pack on so you say as big
as you can you make a lot of noise and a
lot of big movement does it kind of
intimidate it and scare it it might come
out a little bit and then turn away but
if it comes at you the only thing you
can do is fight the bear go for the nose
go for eyes and good luck